Let's talk about the Unreal Build Tool or the UBT.
As we've just seen,
Unreal is fundamentally split into modules
and the engine has got a lot of them.
This tool essentially regenerates your project solution
by iterating over all build.cs files,
discovering new DLLs that it needs to build,
as well as adding any new target.cs files
that you may have added as configuration options.
The Unreal Build Tool runs totally independently
from any development environment
and can be accessed through a contextual button
on the U project file.
You should rerun the UBT every time files are added
or removed from the project.
Let's take a look at what it does under the hood.
When we initialize the build tool, the following happens.
The UBT takes a project, target platform,
and a configuration,
and then gathers all of the target.cs files
and the build.cs files for its modules.
With the specified target,
it will create an instance of that target
and then find all of the modules, source code,
and plugins required to successfully build that target.
We'll then look for all the header files for the modules,
looking specifically for files
that contain Unreal-related metadata.
It then passes those header files
to the Unreal header tool or the UHT for parsing
to create the generated code
which gets fed back into the Unreal Build Tool.
The UBT then generates an action graph,
which is a graph full of all the compilation
and linking operations needed
to be performed to build the desired project
for a specified target and configuration.
The action graph, which are essentially just cl.exe
or link.exe nodes with parameters applied,
gets saved into a makefile
so that it doesn't need to keep doing
these steps constantly.
It will then execute the action graph to build two projects
with an executer to compile all .obj files
and link them to .exe or .dlls and PDBs.
Realistically, as engineers,
we're unlikely to interact with either the UBT
or the UHT directly,
aside from rerunning it when we update our project.
But it's important that we at least
have a cursory knowledge of what happens under the hood
before going forward.
Unlike raw C++, Unreal's flavor of C++
fully supports reflection,
and for the most part, it revolves around the UObject.
The Unreal Reflection System,
which is otherwise known as the Property System,
is an opt-in system that gives the program
the ability to examine itself at runtime.
This system not only powers our game projects,
but also the engine and its constituent parts.
All reflected types are based off of UObject,
with UObject being the lowest class
that we can get to in terms of the Unreal file structure.
Every player, game object, bullet, visual effects, sound cue,
their class hierarchy all eventually lead to UObject.
We can't mention UObject
without pointing out that U prefix.
Unreal has got a strongly enforced naming convention system
that lets us know what the class we're working with
is currently based on.
So as an example, we can see the child classes
that are not based off of actor
have got the U prefix, such as the UData asset.
Actor-derived types have the A prefix,
such as the A exploding barrel.
Structs or non-UObject classes have got the F prefix,
such as the F explosion params or the F archive.
Enums have got the E prefix,
and templated types have got the T prefix,
such as T my templated class,
or T unique pointer with a template being passed in.
To create and mark a file
as containing a reflected system type,
the following must be added to the class.
We add a special include,
that being the hash include of myFileName.generated.h,
we then mark the class with the U class markup,
a struct with a U struct, or an enum with U enum.
We then add the following
within the class declaration body.
We add the generated body macro.
This will generate typedefs and additional functions,
such as static class and static struct,
that are used in the reflection system
to retrieve reflection data from this class.
And that's it.
This type is now part of the Unreal reflection system.
And the editor can actually do this for you.
The editor contains a new class wizard.
It will generate both a header and a CPP file
in a specified location,
and add all of this boilerplate for you.
The above will mark this class as a reflected type,
and it will be subject to that parsing phase
of the Unreal build tool that we spoke about previously.
That being the phase that was looking for files
containing Unreal metadata.
As well as U class,
we can also mark up many other parts of our code
to pass along to the UBT,
giving us extended functionality such as editor visibility
or smart memory management.
We can mark up member variables with U property
to prevent garbage collection from nulling out the pointer,
or functions with U function
to make them callable from blueprint.
U class allows engineers to mark up members within
with additional macros,
as well as provide additional class specifies to this class,
expanding its use.
For example, we have blueprint type,
blueprintable, and abstract,
but there are many other options available
and a full list can be found inside objectmacros.h.
The U property markup is applied to member variables
within a U class,
and much like U class lets us specify property specifies
for a particular member.
Critically, it also prevents garbage collection
from nulling out any cache pointers.
We don't have to manage our own memory
when working with U properties.
They're being reference counted for us.
As long as they're flagged up with the U property macro,
we should be fine.
Some examples of specifies that we would typically see
inside a U project would be edit anywhere.
This value is exposed to property windows in the editor.
Edit defaults only.
This value is exposed to property windows,
but only in archetypes.
Visible anywhere.
This value is visible, but cannot be edited.
Replicated.
This value is liable to network replication.
Additional setup is required
to actually get it to replicate,
but this is just the first step towards getting there.
And then finally we've got transient,
which basically means this property is not serialized
and will be zero filled at runtime.
As with U class,
objectmacros.h has got a more definitive list.
Having discussed the U property macro
and how we can use it to prevent our pointers
from being garbage collected,
it's also important that we discuss a new addition
to Unreal Engine 5, the T object pointer.
Firstly, it's important to note
that the use of raw pointers
is still a totally valid way to store your data.
However, we'd recommend the use
of a T object pointer instead.
A T object pointer is the size equivalent
of a 64 bit pointer,
and will convert to a raw pointer
when passed into functions and stored in local variables.
Its main advantage comes in editor builds
where it supports lazy load behavior,
which will speed up your engine boot times.
The T object pointer can also cache
resolved object addresses.
So in range based iteration,
it's recommended to use something like an auto ref
or a const auto ref to speed up future access attempts.
In terms of garbage collection,
this will still work the same as a raw pointer,
namely because we still use in conjunction
with the U property macro.
Its other advantage is that it supports
cook time dependency tracking.
This means that their use is tracked
to build up asset to asset cook dependencies.
The engine itself has already been converted
to use a T object pointer.
So for example, in actor,
the root component variable is now converted
to use a T object pointer.
So any direct interactions with this variable
will need to be updated.
However, the get root component still returns
the same U scene component pointer.
Similar in implementation to U property,
U function allows engineers
to give different functionality to a function
based off of the meta specified.
For instance, blueprint callable,
this function can be called from blueprint.
Blueprint cosmetic,
this function will not be run on dedicated servers.
So think playing VFX or a sound cue.
We've then got server,
this function is replicated and executed on the server.
When this is called on a client,
its implementation will be executed on the server.
So think passing input information
from the client back up to the server.
We've then got client, similar to server,
this function is replicated and executed on the client.
When this is called on the server,
its implementation will be called on the client.
So think UI updating based off of authoritative information.
We've then got net multicast
and this function is replicated as well.
And when called on the server,
the implementation is fired everywhere.
So that would be locally on the server
as well as on any relevant clients.
These networked functions
are called remote procedure calls or RPCs.
Structs and enums also have their own reflection markup
that being the U struct and U enum respectively.
U struct, much like all other types of markup
supports meta, the most common of which
being the blueprint type,
which lets us use this type in the editor.
What it also does is allow us to mark up members
of the struct itself as U property,
much like we would in a U class.
In this way, we can have pointers inside of structs
with no fear of them being GC'd erroneously.
U enums also support blueprint type as a meta
and it lets us add U meta
to individual members of the enum.
For example, we can hide the max member
of an enum from being shown in the editor
as max members are typically only used for iteration,
not actual gameplay designs or implementations.
By no means are these the only reflection meta specifiers,
they're just the most common examples.